so this week dish decided to throw their
hat in the ring to purchase sprint it
means you'd be able to watch anything
you have on your dish network on your
phone really so if I'm like a sprint
customer and I have a sprint handset or
tablet or something I can watch like
anything I've recorded on my dish DVR
well more important than just a video on
demand you could watch live TV on your
phone they would be pushing your
satellite bundle through the mobile
network the device we're going to talk
about this week is the samsung galaxy
note 8.0 it's an 8-inch tablet this is
the fourth galaxy note device there's
the first two Galaxy Note smartphones
which have five inch screens and then
the Galaxy Note 10 which is a 10 inch
tablet so this one slots right in
between the larger tablet and the
smartphone now what sets this tableau
apart from a lot of out tablets is the S
Pen it's really just a stylish but
Samsung which is called the S Pen
because probably cuz it's super small in
my giant hand it's really hard to use in
my hand gets very tired without hard to
use i well it's it so it's helpful for
drawing but I would rather just I would
end up buying an actual different
stylist for this thing so it's running
Android jelly bean and it's been
optimized for pen input by Samsung so
you can use the pen to navigate around
the whole operating system from flipping
through pages to tapping on menus in the
web browser inside the sketchbook app
you can draw little circles and squares
and lines and make flow charts or
abstract art now the screen is obviously
larger than the note smartphones which
has a 5.5 inch screen now it's it's
eight so it does work you know it does
fit in my hand I can hold it but for
other people it could be a little bit
difficult now if you have a tinier hands
like Alexandra here i have i have
monstrous hands it's difficult to use
one hand and use the stylus it's it's a
pretty cumbersome use case if you have
yet for use with two hands up that's
fine take away the pen and you're left
with a pretty generic tablet there's
nothing really exotic about it it feels
mostly plastic and
a little bit cheap which is strange
considering that it starts at four
hundred dollars now that's twice as much
money as one of Google's Nexus 7 tablets
which is two hundred bucks for seven
incher and it's a full seventy dollars
more expensive than the base model of
the iPad Mini which is also an 8-inch
tablet so you're really paying the big
bucks for the pen and honestly I didn't
really miss the pen when it moved away
from this to other tablets so unless you
really really want a pen there's really
not much of a reason to consider
spending four hundred dollars on this
now I do like the the mid-size the
smaller tablet market because these are
things you can throw in your backpack
and travel traveling with a huge tablet
is a pain in the ass that's another
reason I'm fan of the smaller form
factor is that while I'm reading in bed
or on the couch I don't get a lot of
that because of the weight yeah I I
really enjoy reading with it especially
more so than an iPad which is really
heavy and I just like smaller tablets
I'm finding all kinds of uses for them